I mean,
I would like to know what the number is.
If the church is in this country,
had to pay taxes.
That mean clearly,
especially when you look at the televangelists that are driving rolls Royces and
flying around in private jets.
I mean,
there's profit is extreme amount of profit and it's discretionary income.
They could do whatever they want with it and you're,
you're dealing with massive,
massive sums of money and they don't contribute.
So these people are clearly personally benefiting from the contributions of
these people.
And then they don't pay taxes on it.
And in the case of like,
ministers who live in a church owned home,
they don't have to pay property tax.
Uh,
you know,
there's a lot of hidden benefits there.
It's dirty,
it is dirty.
It's amazing that it's still here.
I mean,
especially when you deal with something like Scientology,
we'll,
you know,
the guy who wrote it,
right?
Like it's,
this is not some ancient texts that were handed down from,
uh,
you know,
the guy and the guy was a terrible writer.
I mean,
he was a terrible science fiction author.
He just wrote every fucking thing he wrote was a first draft.
Just just boom,
gone.
I mean,
it's just the most nonsensical nonsense writing,
and yet they don't have to pay taxes because it's considered a legitimate
religion.
Harless Arlin Ellison,
the great science fiction writer died this year.
Uh,
told me the story of what the famous story where l Ron Hubbard allegedly said,
you know,
I'm going to go start a religion.
He said it was,
it's real.
It's a true story.
They were,
but it was just a bunch of science fiction writers sitting around like this
chatting and complaining about how poorly paid they are.
They have to crank out by the word,
you know,
Kenny a word kind of thing.
And somebody said,
you know,
we should just start a religion and make shit up like that,
and I'll run.
Hubbard goes,
yeah,
you know,
that's a good idea,
I think.
I think I might do that.
And then he went out and wrote dianetics and that became the founding document
of Scientology.
Did you watch the,
the HBO series on it?
The documentary rather?
Yeah,
the going clear.
Unbelievable.
That's the best documentary on it.
Of course,
I've seen Aaliyah's show she's got a big guts to go after.
I don't know if she's got good lawyers are a,
and he has good lawyers or whatever.
Maybe they've stopped suing people.
I don't know.
I think the climate has shifted and I think people were more,
first of all,
for the longest time all we thought of when you thought about Scientology,
thought about positive thinking and John Travolta and Tom Cruise,
they're all super positive,
you know,
and they're getting things done and there's auditing and they're really taking
care of their mind and you know,
and thinking clearly and eliminating all the negative influences.
But then once I'm,
there was a bunch of factors I think,
but once the Internet opened up these,
the,
the doctrines and you've got a chance to read it and people got a chance to mock
it and then,
you know,
South Park did that whole series on it where they are,
this is what they actually believe.
And you see like when south park did that,
everybody was like,
Holy Shit,
wait a minute,
is that real?
And then people started googling it and then looking into it and then it started
to unravel.
Slowly but surely people started leaving the church,
Lawrence Wright wrote the book,
all these things are happening and now Leah is coming in and Leah was,
you know,
I knew her,
but I mean I'm friends with Kevin James from the king and Queen.
So I,
I've known Leah for 20 plus years and when I first met her,
she was just like this hard ass beautiful woman who's just like driven and like,
like she said,
Scientologists were like,
oh,
let's get the fuck out of her way.
You know?
It was like that.
She's just like super active and just getting things done and just being
productive.
I mean,
that's what you thought about when you thought about Scientology,
but now when you think about it is like nonsense and it's foolishness and,
and once going clear air and you've got to see l Ron Hubbard and listened to him
talk and you see the captain's outfit he had on with the metals that he gave
himself.
Like what?
Who would buy this stuff?
It's so dumb.
It's just,
it's amazing that it,
it's so effective and so financially successful.
I,
yeah,
I think their membership roles are pretty low,
but their property holdings I think are pretty substantive.
Yeah.
I mean,
they're the second biggest real estate owner in Los Angeles.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
At least they were,
there was some,
uh,
Japanese folks that were number one and then it was a number two was
Scientology.
Maybe that's not true anymore.
Might be a oil barons.
Now,
you know,
well back in the 90s,
when the Internet first got cranked up,
we were doing issue is articles on Scientology is when some of these ex members
started posting the secret doctrines,
the z news story and the going clear at level eight or whatever.
When you find out the,
the,
the inside story and they got raided,
I mean the Scientologists went to court to court the judges and said,
uh,
this is copyrighted material.
And it's like,
wait,
your religion,
how can you copyright of religious?
Well,
and they somehow got around that,
I mean,
this would be like the Catholic church not telling you about Jesus.
And the resurrection until level eight after you've paid $100,000 or something
like that.
It's just insane.
Well,
what's amazing is that the IRS caved in terms.
Unbelievable.
When that happened,
I remember when that happened,
I thought,
oh my God,
I don't want to fuck with these guys.
I mean,
they beat the IRS.
I'm a nobody.
How am I going to defend myself again?
But maybe they've stopped suing people.
Maybe they're not going after Leah.
Like la real estate here goes portfolio properties reported at $400 million in
Hollywood alone,
paid for in cash.
No left.
The Church of Scientology is undeniably a formidable player in the real estate
game.
Wow.
That's what you got.
They have some beautiful properties too.
Yeah.
It's just really amazing.
It's amazing.
So you know my,
my skeptic frenzy,
oh,
they're going to go out of business anytime soon.
It's like,
I don't know.
I think they could have practically no members instilled.
They have all this real estate.
Here's the thing,
even though it's nonsense,
just so is most religion,
let's just be honest.
I mean,
if you want to talk about guys coming back from the dead after being burned for
three days,
or Adam and eve being the only two people and they have kids and their kids just
started having sex with each other and that makes all the people in the world,
or Moses parting the Red Sea and Jesus walking on water.
I mean,
you're looking at horse shit everywhere.
It's just older horse shit.
It's,
you know,
whether or not it's based on some real events or certain real people who knows,
who knows?
You know,
but it's all nonsense.
If you ever heard a Julius Sweeney's monologue letting go of God.
Now,
do you know Julia from Saturday night live?
I know who she is.
I do not know her.
Yeah,
she just moved back to La.
So you should have her on the show.
She's terrific love to.
So,
um,
she was born and raised Catholic love being a Catholic,
the whole culture and all that was great.
And then she started reading Dawkins and me and Harrison saw on and then kind of
let all that go.
And then she wrote a monologue.
It's very moving.
So the model like opens,
she's in her house in Hollywood and the Mormon boys come by and she invites them
in and they want to tell the story and she's thinking,
this is like a Hollywood pitch story.
You're going to pitch the story and I'll get back to you later until you know
how I like it.
No,
no.
They wanted to,
you know,
to actually,
press to see if she could join right then and there.
You know,
they're on their two year mission that they do,
you know,
so picture of these two 18 year olds with their white starched shirts and their
bicycles.
And so Julia starts pressing him a little bit.
So,
so what's the story here?
Well,
see,
this guy,
Joseph Smith,
he,
he found these gold plates in his backyard and he translated to them from
ancient,
uh,
hieroglyphics into English and with these magic stones and they're going on.
And then Jesus came to America and there was the good Indians and the bad
Indians at Julie's.
Like,
I just want to tell them,
okay,
don't start with this story.
This is a bad pitch story.
Even the Scientologists,
no,
don't tell him about Xenu until way down the line.
But then she says,
reflecting on it,
you know,
if,
if I told somebody my Catholic story who never heard of it,
it would sound just as wacky cause it's virgin and the resurrection.
What?
Yeah.
All of it's wacky.